To continue through all the debuggers, I'm simply going to close the web
console and see what gets displayed in my chart.
And as you can see here, we've drawn one blue circle for
every game of the World Cup throughout the years.
Now, there's a few style issues, I'm going to clean up simply with some CSS.
Mainly, the width of the access lines, the years on the x-axis, and
something you may not be able to notice here,
is that there's a lot of overlap in the circles.
So by adding some opacity to the circles, you can see similar to what we
saw in the Facebook IPO example, some overlap to know the density of points.
So again, using CSS to style my axis and my SVG circles,
in my text, the chart looks much nicer and much crisper.
I don't want to go, spend the time to go through every one of the CSS changes
I've made, but if you're interested, and you're comfortable enough with CSS,
I encourage you to look back at the files and
use the CSS resource we have provided, to understand better what's going on.
So after all of these updates, that we've made in D3,
we finally have a equivalent chart that we made in dimple js,
with its short five lines, but again by converting our previous chart to D3,
it's going to allow us much more flexibility to add both interaction and
to customize the look and feel of the chart.
And when all is said and done, took only approximately 40 or
more lines of D3 to recreate what we've done in dimple in five.
But if you're going to be a stickler about it, each of
these statements here technically is one line, one long chain of functions.
But for clarity's sake, I've written every new function call on a new line